[Music]
in competitive farming news what the
[ __ ] the most boringest thing ever oh
yeah you ain't frame barely
submitted by rubbing styrofoam I hate
that noise I could hear it in my briefs
competitive virtual farming is getting
its own eSports League shot though front
door is it the farm game like Farmville
that's amazing oh there's like a
crossing over Animal Crossing that's
what it is
harvest harvest moon yeah harvest moons
one of our two valves and eagerly
farming simulator farming simulator I
got that game that's the main one that
is like doing although I could see why
though so now they're farming simulators
[ __ ] tight doesn't work because
farming simulator is like you're an
actual farmer so imagine like it's
[ __ ] World of Warcraft or like any
other like RPG kind of [ __ ] right but
you're a farmer and then two fairies
come tomato booms right but tomato clues
with a fat dick and they're like listen
we do make more baby tomatoes so the
[ __ ] farming Fairy comes and jacks
off the tomato and Itsuki's Papa farming
Championships so what they do is that
that's a decade oh that's hard to do
yeah but they're actually using like the
actual way of like how the machines work
do you know you know how I got that game
I was watching a walkthrough and then I
I literally watch like three hours of it
because each walkthrough is about an
hour and I was like I can't wait anymore
and I downloaded the game on my laptop
and I played that [ __ ] but since I don't
have a mouse - it's hard yeah it's like
doing that first-person shooter with
your [ __ ] it's hard as hell you could
buy all this [ __ ] till you get loans and
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] dope let's talk about
it they're saying that it's like real
life simulation of like what it is to
farm yeah something like that I don't
know no no it's like this it's like this
imagine if you can have a business game
sounds boring ready
it's [ __ ] dope it's like that well
they never play game they don't even
play games
yeah they don't even play it's not even
get it but see that's not that's why
it's [ __ ] dope is because you get to
make money you get to loan buddy money
from the bank you get to grow crops and
[ __ ] you got [ __ ] chickens so while
you're making money here your little
money in real I know I mean tell that to
a 12 year old you know like but you're
not 12 and you love it I know I love it
but you know what it's not easy for me
to [ __ ] it up and go and build a farm
right like there's a lot of things that
I'd seems perfect yeah it's [ __ ]
awesome what does that called [ __ ] when
you live through it vicarious Leon no no
no the other one yes cathartic
I like Sims a lot but only if I got the
cheat and have a million dollars oh do
motherlode hell yeah so I could just
build whatever I wanted and then I then
after that I would just burn everybody
inside and kill them all
decorate die yeah oh my god so the game
studio called giant software they're
from Switzerland they announced that
they will be making an eSports
competitive league and that they will be
committing 250,000 euros or
approximately two hundred and eighty
five thousand dollars as prize money
whoever can it's amazing the best page
backer that's one of them one of the
events I imagine competing in these as
opposed to like little like Asian kids
I imagine the middle-aged white house
wife that stays a whole handsome girl on
Facebook competing in these you know the
whole composition is capri pants flats
my [ __ ] mom with hella good at dr.
Mario dude oh yeah [ __ ] pill geisha I
could not beat her at all of you that
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] good at that game
you hit it huh cuz you're like you can't
beat me yeah that's amazing though like
if that's why I blows my mind that
there's still people in first world
countries that are struggling to make
money because I'm like money is [ __ ]
everywhere like you can make money off
of anything over the week we were
writing our film right and then we were
staying at this hotel that was housed by
a lot of like eSports crews like there's
a lot of teams there right and we were I
was talking to one of the dudes and he
was like yeah they had this competition
it's like it's what was it dota the fort
fortnight what's the other one Red Dead
Redemption no no no it's more popular
than fortnight right now but it's like
fortnight G pub G club BG so they were
having that competition right now
alright and then and he was like he was
like yeah they just crowdfunded for the
proud prize money 28 million in
competition the prize money
have you seen competitions now I need
again like in arenas I've been away
Alma came with you but I'm gonna game in
a [ __ ] bikini oh now we're talking
they make so much [ __ ] money do you
get a lot of glitter Albert talking do
that much worried are you just gonna
want to be the best dog I need a gimmick
i need a hook you know means got to do
your [ __ ] what do you call the the
[ __ ] what's it called the JK party in
a bikini and then [ __ ] just every
video probable moment no but this one
aren't believe my house pick up in this
whole tower like few months now i know
what your hug you hustle I see you as
but you ain't in a bikini
are you a messy be if you were in a
bikini don't question it if I was in a
bikini playing in so it makes so much
money I don't you you better [ __ ] to
sell that [ __ ] [ __ ] is they think
it's like you're they called boobie
streamers they're like oh you're [ __ ]
good who [ __ ] say that's why I don't
give a [ __ ] about people laughs [ __ ]
get your self-esteem low cuz you lost to
me and Jack off to me [ __ ] and the
brazier self esteem others make so much
money the age-old thinking of games is a
waste of time and all that stuff that
shit's ancient so much money beating
every industry is there's this guy who's
a Mike is gonna start playing tomorrow
he went to he went to law school and
decided to go after but like you know do
people do like criminal law and [ __ ]
like that he's like no I'm gonna do like
eSports law really but to represent them
and this is way before this got big now
he's making a [ __ ] ton of money because
he's the only lawyer that does it for
all these eSports teams what do they
need lawyers were like oh contracting
competitions because it's an actual
business you know yeah so he's making so
much I had patients to play games man I
got too much [ __ ] ATD man who's gonna
find the right game yeah but this video
games to treat a TD video games is
perfect for a TD yeah
really yeah focus when I play you play
by I play [ __ ] GTA 48 hours straight
okay touch read dead because I can't do
that because I'll play a game and then
I'm like I'm over it next one and
they'll go how I am that's how you were
with Diablo
well Diablo was different right what was
different though it's because I like
because all my friends were playing it
too that's the point but they don't play
it I didn't play it that's the only game
I got into not diablo but tetra net so I
never I played games but the games I had
community yeah we played it here yeah I
played it every day to play it's like
4:00 a.m. in the hell yeah with your
buddies ever since I got the surgery on
the eye yeah like I can't focus on
something that long my I start to tear
up and I get straight ice cream oh I
can't do it anymore
power through it I can't do it because
it's still like my eyes hurt please do
the pie you're too obsessed if I touch
it that's like oh my god you would go
nuts and read dead dude like remember
we're playing that [ __ ] what was that
we that we game that your house oh all
over could you switch I got it for Isaac
for his birthday we got him a little
bunch of switch games I'm economist
which and Casey and I we join him and
we're there for like two hours or like
[ __ ] grounded for not getting the
tomatoes go to your [ __ ] room a
little [ __ ] feet doctor troll because
then like we're trying to get the orders
done right and then you'll feel like
accidentally accidentally died and like
we need him and you're dead for like
five seconds we're like you know what
you're dead to me too [ __ ] seriously I
think we're trying to get a goal done
after you left we stayed for like
another two hours to get that [ __ ]
thing do you know how hard it was for me
to leave all right see it's I wanted to
go run it again run it again we got a
[ __ ] beat this [ __ ] dude we got a
[ __ ] beat it you know our goal is
always the three stars and well we feel
like two stars it's gonna come on I know
me to reassess what happened here we
need to make sure we had the regrouping
[ __ ] all right now you gonna get the
burger
I'll get the lettuce we stay by the
lettuce those fingers Thanksgiving I've
ever had in my life dude oh so sweaty I
love it but I still don't like being in
a confined space for too long now so
like I have to be outside like I have to
be outside if I don't go outside I
[ __ ] lose my finding put your table
outside get the Sun while you play I
can't even touch it man if I read it
would be amazing that's why I don't have
any console I don't have anything do not
your [ __ ] you lose your job would
disappear dude I never thought I would
spend so much money on a [ __ ] PC in
my life now I'm on my second one you got
a crazy gaming PC yeah I'm a PC gamer I
like PC better too it's just I'm so used
to it from the counter-strike days I
hate the games where I have to move the
camera to see where I'm going oh yeah
it's like so slow yeah I don't like this
though when they [ __ ] re-release
[ __ ] bottle Fantasy 7 though that
[ __ ] remake can we play together and
cry a hundred percent you guys were
[ __ ] elephants because I could do
that because of nostalgia it's on crack
now the [ __ ] hand doesn't look like
this just blah when they showed the
[ __ ] gameplay it was unfuckin real
dude I think all of like the internet
died when they announced that it was
amazing I remember that day like I
remember 9/11 dude I saw though all
probably the other games I like our
slasher games like muck in Dynasty
Warriors I just like obliterating in
crowds people come up to you and you
just slice everybody in half and it
makes me feel if you hear all their
screams you're like 300 screams it's
awesome that's why nobody goes out
anymore I'm so pale
[Music]